si es para ti específicamente el día de
hoy cierran las campañas electorales en
todo el ecuador para pasar a partir del
día de mañana lo que comienza el
silencio electoral el día de hoy también
el candidato de la esperanza en tres
aros cierra su campaña lo hizo el día de
hoy en la gente que supo entender lo
hace en la ciudad de guayaquil mientras
tanto al candidato isaac pérez también
lo hace en la ciudad de cuenca todos han
pasado tanto por quitó podemos por la
ciudad de guayaquil y lo que se ha dicho
por parte de las autoridades es el
exhorto a distintos partidos políticos
para que eviten las aglomeraciones el
nuevo protocolo de campaña no permite
los mítines solamente permite las
caravanas y caminatas por el cual el día
de hoy cierra en un evento que se
realizó en un lugar simbólico de la
ciudad de quito y poco a poco ya están
pasando por las principales habilidades
anunciadas el consejo nacional electoral
día 50 preparado y de igual modo un muy
fuerte de una fuerte custodia policial
para lo que será el día domingo la
inauguración en este lugar
el inicio del proceso electoral gustavo
pero también sabemos que las elecciones
como usted ya nos adelantaba se realizan
bajo normas de protocolo electoral como
se realizarán entonces las votaciones de
este próximo 7 de febrero
si tales como grises son las normas
sanitarias y de seguridad lo que van a
regir en este momento la campaña
electoral por lo menos para la campaña
electoral sólo permiten caravanas y
caminatas para realizar el voto se
exhorte inclusive a llevar su propio
bolígrafo azul o negro es obligatorio
portar la mascarilla para ir a votar el
voto se realiza en un solo sentido en un
flujo para ingresar y no coincidir con
las personas que ingresan y de igual
forma a la hora de ejercer el voto se
exhorta a votar de acuerdo al número
terminal de la cédula impar o par desde
las 7 de la mañana hasta las 12 del
mediodía y posteriormente hasta las 5 de
la tarde los números pares o impares
según el terminal de la célula